The exercise of inviting you to choose.
Our last novel,
as I think I explained in the very first
class of this term is an exercise in
thinking together about what
defines a period of literature.
So for all the other
books in the syllabus,
I came with my rationale
for why I included them.
And for this book I'm invited again
to think about whether I would,
if I were teaching this again
and you had not chosen it.
So today I want to reflect on that and
it will lead directly into my analysis of
what the Holocaust is doing in this novel.
And then I will have some parting
words for you to conclude the course.
When I think about books to include,
I have four categories that I think about.
One is books that are
somehow representative.
So the books in this course
that fit that bill, uh,
you might think of the ones
that featured the identity plot.
As I argued in that
lecture at mid semester,
the identity plot is a reigning
narrative structure in this period.
And some of the books in our syllabus
culminating in the human stain.
And I think this book too could
be included in that group. Um,
all are representative of different
versions of that narrative structure.
So representative innovative,
I include works on the syllabus that I
consider innovative in the form of the
novel, in the genre of the novel
or for their subject matter.
Somehow they think about something in a
way that I haven't known anything else
to think about before. Um, I
think Lolita fits this model, uh,
very well and in its own way.
The bluest die at that time in the 1970s
took up a subject that had also been
neglected and was innovative
in its subject matter
is a book widely read well,
this book certainly,
uh,
meets that criteria and some
of our other books do as well.
Lolita is one, the human stain
is another, the woman warrior.
Um, pretty much any Morrison
novel you can choose.
Um,
there are lots of books that fit this
criteria and usually when I'm aiming for
is a book that will be both widely read
and something else on my list so that it
covers more than one base.
And finally,
and this is the most,
uh, evanescent category.
Is it somehow excellent or
important in some other way?
Generally for me,
this is an aesthetic category.
So is it an excellent example of writing?
Is it an excellent example
of narrative art? Um,
is it important in what it thinks
about somehow, um, philosophically,
topically in a way that nothing else,
uh,
quite can match?
I talked to you on Monday a little bit
about Jonathan Safran Foer is ambitions
for this novel and his
ambitions in general as he
expresses them in interviews.
I think when I consider this novel,
I know that this is where
forwarders interest truly lies.
I'm sure he wants to be widely read.
I'm sure he wants to be innovative
and that's probably connected with the
excellence or importance
that he's aiming at. Um,
he probably doesn't want
to be representative.
Most writers want to be singular
rather than representative. Um,
but this is where the investment really is
and it's in that category that I think
we find his use of the Holocaust.
It's in the effort to be important to
be writing about something important in
this novel that the Holocaust comes
to have such a place in it or that he
chooses a story that has
the Holocaust at its center.
Now I myself am reserving judgment on
the excellence or importance of this
novel,
but I will say that it is certainly
representative of two things.
One is a version of the identity plot.
It is a novel of a young person to young
people coming to seek out their past
and somehow gained from that
search some sense of themselves.
So it is a version of the identity plot.
It is also representative of late
modernist formal characteristics.
So this is clever in the way that
John Barth is clever with language.
It is funny in the way that pension and
Barth are just drawing from our syllabus
a, it makes some of the kinds of
moves that the woman warrior makes.
So it is representative in that way.
I do not think it innovates formally.
There's nothing I see here formally that
I have not seen elsewhere and before.
So for me it doesn't
quite meet that criteria,
but representative and widely read,
certainly now there is a way in which
I think it could be understood as
innovative.
And my sort of kernel for
thinking about this is on one 85
yeah.
This is in that harrowing
scene where the woman,
they think of as
a Augustine has told them the story
of the murder of the Jews of track and
broad.
And then afterwards the
grandfather confesses to his
complicit conduct with that
murder.
Yeah.
And Alex has,
he's translating for Jonathan
his grandfather's words,
he says in the middle of one 85 you
cannot know how it felt to have to hear
these things and then repeat them.
Because when I repeated them,
I felt like I was making them new again.
Okay.
That phrase,
making them new again is loaded for any
ambitious writer coming after modernism.
Make it new was the dictum that as repower
and held out as defining literature
that could matter formally,
aesthetically, innovatively.
So to make it new in writing is very
closely allied with the project of
modernism.
A formal project
to use that phrase in this emotionally
loaded moment suggest two things.
One is it draws on a whole history of
discourse about genocide and particularly
about the Holocaust that
could be encompassed under
the banner of trauma theory.
Now, some of you may have
encountered trauma theory.
It's a sort of mix of psychoanalysis
and literary criticism that has been
powerful in the past couple of
decades. It's power is waning, I think.
Although there's this new interest in
sociology in trauma now in the former
literary critical version of it,
trauma theorists argued that to tell
the story again to tell the story of a
trauma again was to re-experience it.
This was a way of understanding
representation as human
experience has actual
experience on mediated,
and the special thing about trauma was
it was the only kind of experience.
This is what most trauma theorists argued,
that it was really the only kind of
experience that have this quality to it,
this peculiar quality to it,
that it remained real in the sense of
remaining experience and not becoming
language somehow.
Yeah,
this was a way of imagining language.
Also conversely as being experienced
and for some trauma theorists,
this analysis of language spread out
to other kinds of language so that any
language could be understood
as in some sense traumatic.
And this is a far reach of it.
Much of this work I have to say
was done at Yale by two scholars,
Kathy Caruso and Shoshana Feldman.
Um,
both have now left the institution,
but Yale was very well
known for trauma theory.
It had its applications in Holocaust
studies in particular in the building of
the fortune off archive of
testimony, which is housed here. Uh,
I think in sterling.
Okay.
The effort to make videotapes
of survivors' testimonies
was in part of course a
historical effort to get that knowledge
secure before that generation passed
away to gather as much as could be
known of the human experience of the
Holocaust.
But there was a reason I
think that it was video.
There was a great desire among people
who wrote and thought about and studied
the Holocaust to have that immediacy,
that video, uh, was thought to give.
So rather than have transcribed
testimonies are written testimonies,
you get to see the actual
face and expression of the
person telling that story.
Okay.
This is something that scholars have
felt I have since the founding of the
archive have spent a lot of time
thinking about in theorizing.
In the course of that theorizing,
the word witness has come to have a
very specific and powerful meaning.
The interviewer was to think of herself
or himself as not a questioner or as an
interviewer in the way that we
would usually understand that role,
but rather as a witness
to that person's story,
a witness in the sense
of a judicial witness,
someone who would be in a court to affirm
that something had indeed happened.
There was a sense that was needed in
the context of gathering this evidence.
Witnessing was a theorized in a much
more complex way by Shoshana Feldman and
dory loud, a psychiatrist, um, who is,
I think Dori, lob is still in new
haven. I think he's still at IU.
Um,
but together they wrote a book called
testimony that had a lot to say about
exactly how the witness functions in
relation to the person who's testifying.
And I think you can see the mark of all
of this thought about how the Holocaust
is received in the present
stamping for his work.
So you see it in part in
that little sentence that I
just read to you in saying,
and again it was making it new.
It's as if it's a moment in which trauma
is transmitted through language and is
imagined to be transmitted
in an unmediated way.
So the repetition that
we experience as readers,
all these horrible things are said twice
because we see Alex translating them.
That's dramatize for us by the
device of Alex as translator.
So it's debt to modernism or it the way
it has its eye on modernism behind it is
closely aligned to this understanding of
language and its relationship to trauma.
Now by the time Jonathan Safran
Foer is writing this book,
not only has Holocaust studies established
this whole body of thought about
language,
but there are also many examples of what
you might call the American holocaust
novel. And the one I'm going
to use in my lecture today, uh,
to think about in relation to this is
art Spiegelman's graphic novel mouse.
How many of you have, you have? You have
read it? Okay, good. A bunch of you. Um,
for those who of you who haven't,
it's the story of a character named art
Spiegelman and you'll recognize that
device of course from four.
Um,
art Spiegelman is a cartoonist writing
a book about his father's experiences in
the Holocaust and in concentration camps.
Um,
he goes through the novel
alternating between scenes of art,
interviewing his father of Ladakh,
and then it sinks into Vladeck story in,
there are lots of extended scenes where
we just see Vladik escaping from camps
and making his way through them and so on,
doing all the things that he did to
finally escape with his wife Andrea.
Cool.
We find out fairly early in
the first volume of mouse.
It's a two volume graphic that,
uh,
art's mother killed herself
well after she arrived in America
as an immigrant to having escaped.
And we see her in an inserted cartoon
in a different style in the bathtub.
She slit her wrists in the bathtub.
Okay.
What's striking about that graphic novel?
It's extremely smart in it's meditation
on the relationship between a son and
his father and the relationship between
growing up in America and surviving the
Holocaust.
But what's really striking is it's
meditation on the problem of Arts,
insignificance.
How can his childhood and his child's
problems being bullied at school or
whatever it is.
How can those compete with his father's
experience of having survived the
Holocaust by his own widths?
And by luck,
that dramatic story is
impossible for the sun to match.
And so there are certain ways I have
argued in print a certain ways that art
appropriate his father's story and
imagines himself as a survivor.
So it's a way of transmitting the trauma
of the Holocaust from one generation to
another. And there are lots of, um,
graphic devices and
linguistic tricks that, um,
that Spiegelman uses to affect this.
And A,
I won't go into that detail now, but, um,
it's something that I've argued at length.
Okay.
What makes everything is illuminated
different and I would argue innovative is
that it for me represents
the third generation effort
to recover the Holocaust.
So by the time for his writing,
okay.
These stories have been
told not only by Spiegelman,
his books came out in 1987 and
1991 or [inaudible] 86 and 91,
the two volumes of mouse so well before
four wrote this one forwards just a
child.
Okay.
That was not the only book on the
experience of the Holocaust. Um,
those would include Cynthia Ozick
the shawl. Very famous example.
Um, a little later, a European writer,
German writer living in England,
WG Sebald Road Austerlitz had a
very similar structure of a child,
of the Kindertransport,
someone who had been taken from Prague
to England along with all the other
children,
Jewish children of his,
his neighborhood to save them.
He discovers this as his own past and he
tries to go back and find the traces of
his parents in the concentration camps.
And finally he finds a snippet of film
from one of the concentration camps where
his mother was,
his mother was a singer and he slows
it down further and further and further
just to try to glimpse her face.
This is a story of the hunt for the
beloved parent and for the ground of a
child's identity.
This story has been told many times by
the time for his writing this novel.
In addition,
most of these prior versions and fiction
and Saman memoir have to do with the
first generation American experience so
far finds himself belated in two ways.
One because the story of
the Holocaust and, uh,
finding out that secret has
already been told and to,
because he's not second generation,
he's not the child of a survivor,
but the grandchild of a survivor.
So what do you do to
make that story your own?
If you are committed to its
central valley to who you are,
how do you make that into an
unmediated kind of experience?
One way that that's done,
both in second generation stories.
And I think in this third generation
story is by playing off of and,
um,
excavating the Jewish cultural
veneration for memory.
So in Jewish tradition,
memory of Eh,
of parents of the dead,
of past events is at the
heart of religious practice,
but also have secular versions
of religious practice.
This novel is full of those secular
versions of religious practice.
Um,
and it explicitly talks about children's
relation to the memory of their
parents.
This is on two 68.
Oops,
got my page wrong there. Sorry. To 60.
Okay.
He's describing here the
itch to remember that he,
he, uh, the novel imagines
as particularly Jewish,
but children had it. Worst
of all, for all though,
it would seem that they had
fewer memories to haunt them.
They had the itch of memory as
strong as the elders of the shuttle.
Their strings were not even their own,
but tied around them by
parents and grandparents.
Strings not fastened to anything but
hanging loosely from the darkness.
So you can imagine this story of
Jonathan going back to find the woman who
helped his grandfather escape as an
effort to tie that string to something
concrete.
The fact that he never
can really find that woman
suggests that already internalized
here is something that I'm Holocaust,
uh,
literature coming before this has been
intent on examining and questioning,
which is, can you ever have that
on mediated relation to the past?
Can you ever tie memory back to the event
in a way that feels like it's a real
connection?
So here there's a fairly easy,
if also wistful or ELA gigantic admission
that you can't ever really tie that
string up.
This is why the hunt
is never going to be
successful in the novel.
We will never tie up all
those little details.
It's meant to be that way
because at this late date,
it's clear that's the
only way it could be.
And that's not innovative.
It's simply, uh,
where the genre is right now.
However,
this novel is loath to part with the
drama that earlier stories made from the
recovery narrative.
So for Jonathan,
the mystery is not what happened to
his parents during the hall to his
grandparents during the Holocaust.
That's the classic question.
The parents won't talk about what
happened. The child wants to know,
the child knows there's something back
there and the hunt is to find out exactly
what happened.
And usually it's hidden either
because the parent left,
a prior child
lost a prior child or somehow felt
guilty about surviving either because of
explicit acts where they were forced
to sacrifice someone in their family in
order to escape or in order to help
someone else in their family escaped.
They were forced to choose.
And we see that choice thematized
in Holocaust sections of this novel.
Um, so there's that hiddenness
of the Holocaust experience.
That's not what's hidden in this novel.
Okay.
That history is not what
Jonathan doesn't know.
He knows his grandmother survived
the Holocaust. That's not a mystery.
The mystery is who helped her,
who helped his grandfather,
sorry.
It's the grandfather who helped
his grandfather to escape.
That's the mystery.
Augustine is the mystery woman.
The photograph represents that
missing or hidden knowledge.
Okay.
That this drops out of the picture
of the novel relatively painlessly.
He'll never find her is I think the mark
of how the story of hiding something
that's hidden gets displaced onto Alex.
So what I see here is the transfer of
the story of they hadn't passed from the
hidden past of the victim's side of the
Holocaust to they hadn't passed of the
perpetrator's side.
This is a displacement of that
narrative onto the perpetrators.
So now it's Alex who is looking
to find the secret buried in the
dysfunctionality of his family.
Now it's Alex who finds in speaking to
his grandfather some explanation for why
his father is such a tyrant
and the same logic of memory and
genealogy that you see in the way Jewish
families are talked about
in their relation to memory,
in history between generations
that is reproduced.
As the father says,
you are responsible for your son.
The father is responsible for the son.
Somehow the father is reflected in
the sun. So the choice that Alex,
his grandfather made to point out his
friend Herschel as a Jew and to thus give
him up to the murderous Nazis.
This is somehow played out
in the dysfunctionality of
the family in the present,
in the terrible rages and
drunkenness of the father.
Okay.
It's interesting to me that this novel
is about making the relationship between
grandchildren and grandparents
as immediate as possible.
And so I think it's really
interesting that we have Alex,
um, disowning his father.
You are not my father.
He says at the end of the novel as he
throws his father out of the house.
Essentially
it's a way of getting the
second generation out of the
way and hopping into that
space. So you can see it in the
second and third generation structure.
You swipe the parents out of the way and
you hop into their place as immediately
descended from the people
who experienced these events.
Yeah.
A problem for Americans writing about
the Holocaust is that even if you ama
grated here as a survivor,
this is not the land of those events.
And so I think this gives us some insight
into the use of the European setting.
Europe is where the
important history happened.
That's why a novel trying to be important
in these terms has to be set there.
So if you set out looking for
an important subject matter,
you need that historical
grounding and it's not in America.
It's in Europe.
Okay.
On one 17 you can see very clearly how
the story of Augustine and Alex picks up
the trope of witnessing and it's of course
accomplished through Alex's butchered
English.
This is on one 17 where he
holds the photograph out
Augustine and he says,
have you ever witnessed
anyone in this photograph?
She examined it for several
moments. No, I do not know why,
but I inquired again. Have you ever
witnessed anyone in this photograph?
No. She said again though this second,
no. Did not seem like a parrot,
but a different variety of,
no.
Have you ever witnessed
anyone in this photograph?
I inquired and this time I held
it very proximal to her face.
Like grandfather held it to his face?
No,
she said again and this seemed
like a third variety of, no,
I put the photograph in her hands.
Have you ever witnessed anyone in the
photograph? No. She said, but in her,
no, I was certain that I could hear.
Please persevere choir me again,
so I did. Have you ever witnessed
anyone in the photograph?
She moved her thumbs over the faces as
if she were attempting to erase them?
No. Have you ever witnessed
anyone in the photograph?
No. She said and she put
the photograph on her lap.
Have you ever witnessed anyone in
the photograph? I inquired, no.
She said still examining it,
but only from the angles of her eyes.
Have you ever witnessed
anyone in the photograph? No.
She was humming again with more volume.
Have you ever witnessed anyone in
the photograph? No. She said No.
I saw a tear descend to her white
dress it to withdraw and leave a mark.
Have you ever witnessed anyone in the
photograph? I inquired and I felt cruel.
I felt like an awful person,
but I was certain that I was performing
the right thing. No, she said,
I have not.
They all look like strangers.
I paralled everything.
Has anyone in this photograph
ever witnessed you?
Another tier descended.
I have been waiting for you for so long
here,
that effort through witness to come to
an unmediated connection with the past
and with the violence of the
Holocaust, it's acted out. It is,
as Alex said,
performed by that almost liturgical
repetition of the question and the answer
and the way that Augustine's body gets
closer and closer to the photograph.
She touches the faces.
She finally merges herself
and the photograph by
letting her tears fall on it.
So the question is,
have you ever witnessed for these people
she has not yet because no one has come
to hear her witness.
And I'm reminded then of
the structure of those, um,
survivor testimonies on video where a
witness is required in order for the story
to be told.
And so Augustine,
now she has not witnessed because
she did not have a witness.
Now she has her witnesses
and she will witness to them.
Okay.
And so Alex comes to be
undone by what he finds about himself,
what he finds out about his grandfather
and his family in the second generation
story.
Often it is the family
of the second generation,
the child of the survivor who is undone
by what they find out about their
parent.
So here again,
the structure of the narrative
is transferred to the
perpetrator's side and who
is lying in the bath
with their wrists cut,
not the survivor,
but the perpetrator.
So you get that image from mouse
transferred into the perpetrator's family.
What I find I'm
quite remarkable
about the formal
techniques of this novel is how they
finally reflect on that transfer of the
narrative from the Holocaust
literature to the perpetrators story.
And if you look on one 60 we
can begin to see how this works.
Okay?
Fuel recall,
uh,
they are sitting in the
silence and darkness
together,
peeling corn for Augustine.
And Alex takes Jonathan's diary
and opens it and he says on one 59,
this is what I read,
he told his father that he could
care for her mother and little Igor.
It took his saying it to make
it true. Finally, he was ready.
His father could not believe this thing.
What he asked what,
and Sasha told him again that he
would take care of the family,
that he would understand if his
father had to leave and never return,
and that it would not even
make him less of a father.
He told his father that he would forgive.
Oh,
his father became so angry,
so full of wrath.
And he told Sasha that he would kill him.
And Sasha told his father that he would
kill him and they moved at each other
with violence in his father said,
say it to my face, not to the floor.
And Sasha said,
you are not my father.
So in this scene,
Alex begins to understand
that
cool.
Jonathan is using him as a character and
moreover that Jonathan has penetrated
right into the most intimate and
painful part of his family life,
his relationship with his father
and his fictionalizing. That
and of course,
if you turn to the end,
I hope you recognize this on two 74
this is in fact this passage from his
history,
what we are given as the letter
from the grandfather to Jonathan.
And there it is. This is what
happened. He took his father, uh,
he told his father that he could,
he could care for mother and little Igor.
It took his saying it to make a true.
Finally he was his father could
not believe this thing. What?
And so it goes on to the end
of that paragraph and you
can see culminating as in
the diary with say it to my face,
not to the floor, and Sasha said,
you are not my father.
What are we to make of this?
So this is a bit of postmodern cleverness,
if you will,
raising questions as have
been raised in the human stain
about who exactly is writing this account,
whether it's Coleman or
Nathan in that novel.
How it is that Nathan
knows what Coleman thinks,
how he knows all that happened,
all that he says he knows he has
that happened in coalmines life.
Well here at the very end of the novel
when four brings out this passage that
has been provided much earlier
in Jonathan's notebook,
we are led to question the authorship
of all the letters in the book.
Now of course we know it's a novel.
We know it's all written
by Jonathan Safran Foer.
But in the logic of the novel itself,
Awareness.
Now verges towards this question,
it's not just the reader
who's meant to question this,
but the novel asks us
directly to question.
So what does it mean that Jonathan is
revealed to be the author of this letter?
Well,
there are a couple ways of looking at it.
There are those passages in the
book of antecedents. Remember the,
um,
the Jewish book of memory that
the tracking broaders right?
Over time,
some of those entries are prophetic.
They tell the future,
and we're given a,
an excerpt from that book
that describes the disaster.
And so we know that something like
precedents is a quality of Jewish writing
imagined in this way as a
kind of religious practice.
So either we can understand Jonathan
as carrying on that tradition,
that what he writes in his
diary is similarly proleptic.
It looks towards the future
and transcribes the future.
Or we can see it as
constructing the future itself.
So we can see it either as imagining
what will inevitably happen or as making
the future out of those words.
I think we're meant to feel
both residences to this
formal trick or this formal
device,
but the resonance of Control of making
it happen leads us to I think quite an
interesting place and leads me to wonder
whether this is not a novel of revenge
to transpose the story of a survivor of
the Holocaust who later much later in
their life finally comes to terms
with that terror and commit suicide to
transpose that well worn story,
well known story into the perpetrator's
life and family is a way of giving back
to the complicit,
the pain of the victims.
Okay,
so I think this is quite interesting.
Even though there are
so many moments where,
yeah,
that sense of fault is mitigated.
Would you not do the same?
That question gets asked
who would do differently?
How would you decide what to do?
We're given examples of listas father who
won't spit on the Torah even though he
is not a religious man and watches us,
his entire family is killed and then
finally spits so that he can be killed too
were given all kinds of morally ambiguous,
impossible situations,
situations really where moral machinery
isn't appropriate or possible to think
through.
Okay.
But still
there is that sense that a controlling
author has scripted this future for this
particular family in the present.
Yeah,
so that makes it quite interesting to
me in the, I just want to look on to 62
at another way that transposing the
story outside of the Jewish community
radiates out in this novel
and maybe mitigates that
suggestion of a revenge plot
and this is on two 62 when suddenly
the first person plural appears.
I don't know if you noticed it when you
were reading. I found it quite striking.
This is talking about the people of the
shuttle in their last months of life.
They waited to die and we cannot blame
them because we would do the same and we
do do the same.
Okay.
Yeah. Ask that question implicitly,
would you do anything differently?
Would you go about your normal life?
What would you do?
Okay.
And he says,
we would do the same.
But he also says we do do
the same as if mortality,
the fact of mortality,
the fact that we all are
all of us waiting to die.
And in the meantime,
not thinking about that inevitable end,
going about our daily life with joy
and play and all the range of human
experience and emotion.
He says that that is and Nalagan this
to what these people were doing even
though there and looks so different from
the one that Jonathan Safran Foer the
character in this novel
expects to have for himself.
So the Holocaust story and the reflection
that it causes back on the activities
of life radiates out in
a universalist sense.
It doesn't just impose its narrative
on a new set of participants in the
Holocaust that of the perpetrators
or those who are complicit,
but it radiates out to all
people past and present.
So it becomes a quality of the human
condition. This is a softening move,
I think.
Um,
it suggests the tragedy involved
in all sides of this story.
The tragedy of the simple man
trying to save his wife and child.
And in doing so becoming complicit
to the murder of his friend.
So we see that moral complexity and
it feels like tragedy because of the
softening moves.
Now I want to stop there and say
that it's in this innovation,
this change to an established narrative
about genocide and its relation to
literature and writing that I find
this to be an innovative novel.
And if I were teaching a course,
which I used to teach regularly
on genocide and literature,
I would probably be very
happy to end with this novel,
for that line of analysis of this period.
It's very appropriate
as an innovative ending.
I think though in this novel it is partly
there as a way of taking on something
really hard.
So I talked a little bit on Monday about
the quality of this novel as a campus
novel, um, as the product
of a young person.
And I was joking with you
a little bit about the um,
the bar being set high for
the achievements. One can,
uh, pull off by the age of 22. Um,
I want to use that fact about
forward that this is a first novel,
that it's an especially and overtly
ambitious novel to reflect, um,
on something that's closer to life.
And this is I think something that I've
earned because literature is about,
it's addressed,
addressed to life after all.
That's why we read it
because it strikes us as a,
as a comment on things that are
important to us. If we read,
that's one reason why we read.
So I want to use that question of ambition
also to address something that comes
up in the advising that I do here
for students year in and year out.
And to get at that question, I
want to read you something, uh,
as a good postmodernist
from the 19th century.
This is from Walden,
Henry David Thoreau's Walden.
So we have read a lot of books together.
Um,
this little part I'm going to read to
you from Walden comes after thorough,
has talked about the pleasures
and the virtues of reading.
Um, and then this is in a,
in a section called sounds.
The last section was, uh, was called
reading. This section is called sounds.
I did not read books the first summer.
I hoed beans, nay. I often
did better than this.
There were times when I could not afford
to sacrifice the bloom of the present
moment to any work,
whether of the head or hands.
I love abroad, margin to my life.
Sometimes in a summer morning,
having taken my accustomed Beth,
I sat on my sunny doorway
from sunrise til noon,
wrapped in a reverie amidst the pines
and hickories and Sumacs in undisturbed
solitude and stillness while the birds
saying around or flitted noiselessly
through the house until the sun falling
in at my west window or the noise of
some travelers wagon
on the distant highway.
I was reminded of the lapse of time I
grew in those seasons like corn in the
night and they were far better than
any work of the hands would have been.
They were not time
subtracted from my life,
but so much over and
above my usual allowance.
I hope that your summer,
we'll have a lot of time like that.
I hope that that time might
also have latitude for reading,
and that reading will be not only
what you have been now trained to do,
which is reading that is informed.
If it's contemporary novels,
you're reading informed about
where these writers come from,
what kinds of projects
they might be busy with,
what kinds of questions
they might be responding to,
but also that it will give you time to
enter into and pretend with Novaka often
remember back to the beginning of the
course to pretend with Nepal cough that
you can climb a mountain
of the imagination and meet
a reader there and forget
all the kinds of contexts that I've
been teaching you to pay attention to
because it's in that meeting,
in the imagination that I think literature
can most powerfully speak to you.
So I hope you will go and
have that kind of summer
[inaudible].